With Hollywood studios looking to make every
successful TV show, video game, comic book,
or even board game into a blockbuster movie,
you'd think they would try to adapt that parts
that actually, you know, worked.
You would be wrong, since an amazing world
of mythology and characters can be turned
into absolute garbage pretty easily.
Here are 10 Disappointing Movies That Wasted
Amazing Source Material
Green Lantern (Warner Bros.)
By now we don't really need to go into detail
with just how disappointing Green Lantern
turned out to be, with Ryan Reynolds about
the only part critics and fans didn't tear
apart.
It's still a prime example of how a story
spanning an entire galaxy, countless alien
worlds, heroes, and villains can be completely
wasted on a ridiculous villain, horrible action,
and the idea that a superhero doesn't really
NEED a costume.
X-Men 3: The Last Stand (20th Century Fox)
Recent comic book flops have helped the third
X-Men movie rise by comparison, but even if
The Last Stand delivered some laughs or cool
action, its treatment of Jean Grey is unforgivable.
"The Phoenix Saga" remains one of Marvel's
most iconic stories, seeing Jean be lost to
the cosmic force inside of her.
The movie skipped over so much, they didn't
even need to explain how Professor X came
back to life.
Prometheus (20th Century Fox)
In hindsight, nobody connected to the film
should have ever implied that Prometheus would
actually be a prequel to Ridley Scott's "Alien."
But that's how the movie began its life, before
re-writes weakened or erased the links between
the films - and fans noticed.
While the movie may be epic or visually stunning
in its own rite, and explore some unique ideas
about faith and creators, it will always be
remembered as a failure for using the Alien
brand to build buzz... without actually delivering
on the connection.
Avatar: The Last Airbender (Paramount)
Make no mistake: the Nickelodeon cartoon series
following rival nations of earth, water, fire
and airbenders is one of the best mythologies
created in the past few decades.
But even that couldn't save "The Last Airbender"
from writer/director M. Night Shyamalan.
Even without the insane budget and white-washing
controversy, the movie itself completely avoided
the fun and energy of the series, and failed
at being a decent movie, too.
Wanted (Universal)
A movie doesn't have to be a failure to leave
fans of the comic book it's based on disappointed.
Wanted ended up a story about bullet-curving
assassins killing targets that fate selected,
which is pretty cool - until you realize the
original comic was basically set in the DC
Universe, after the supervillains had won,
and erased heroes from the world's memory.
The movie had the action and comedy to pull
off a story that big, but turned the murder-loving
villains of the comic into proud heroes - which
missed the point for many.
Prince of Persia (Disney)
Sure, we could pick almost any video game
movie and fit this list, but Prince of Persia
was a special kind of awful from the moment
it cast Jake Gyllenhaal as the Persian hero
- and surrounded him with an almost completely
white cast.
But there's a reason the game series lasted
so long, and it's based on thrilling parkour,
witty banter, and epic magic and time travel.
Instead, the movie tried to recreate Pirates
of the Caribbean humor and Disney magic - playing
it safe, and entertaining no one as a result.
Fantastic Four (20th Century Fox)
To be fair, you could probably say the same
about every movie version of Marvel's First
Family, since directors and the studio are
clearly hellbent on making the Fantastic Four
goofy, cheesy, or just boring, carbon-copy
superhero mutants.
Instead of sticking to the sci-fi spectacle,
the fringe science, or just the family drama
that's made the team a hit in Marvel Comics,
Fox has been racing to keep up with Marvel's
other hit franchises - a decision that didn't
just kill the franchise, but killed them in
the comics, too.
Daredevil (Fox)
These days, it's obvious just how good a live-action
Daredevil story can be - which makes the Ben
Affleck-led movie seem like an even bigger
missed opportunity.
Even Marvel's own writers have said Affleck
wasn't really the problem, but the story,
which failed to do justice to either Matt
Murdock the attornee, or the blind crimefighter.
The original, director's cut was actually
a bit better, but when test audiences responded
most strongly to the romance, the studio edited
accordingly - ramping the cheese factor up
along with it.
DOOM (Universal)
The movie has become a punchline for video
game movies in general, but seriously: imagine
a movie starring Karl Urban and The Rock as
space marines travelling to Mars to fight
demon monsters being announced today, and
the hundreds of millions it could make at
the box office.
Since the "DOOM" mythology is as generic as
it gets, the film could have done ANYTHING
it wanted.
Instead, audiences got a movie that was almost
trying to be bad - and don't even mention
the first-person sequence.
Iron Man 3 (Marvel)
Iron Man is still going strong in the MCU,
but after Iron Man 2 took a step down from
Tony Stark's first movie, hopes were high
for Iron Man 3, with the Avenger taking on
the forces of the evil Mandarin.
Fans were already split when Sir Ben Kingsley
was cast in an American-ized version of the
villain, but when the movie's twist revealed
him to just be an actor, playing the deception
for laughs, plenty of fans revolted, calling
it a waste, a bait-and-switch, and a massive
missed opportunity.
Since the MCU doesn't have many, we had to
give this one its due.
Conclusion
Those are just some of the incredible comics,
games and movies that had their potential
wasted in modern adaptations, but which ones
are your most despised?
Let us know in the comments, and subscribe
to our channel for more videos like this one!